bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
au c'ur ert fonce alors on parle
rarement dur kirghizstan dont les médias
occidentaux expliquez-nous brièvement le
contexte politique et économique de ce
pays
bonjour merci de me recevoir
le kirghizstan c'est un pays a
effectivement on parle assez peu malgré
son emplacement stratégique
c'est un petit pays donc de 6 millions
d'habitants le plus démocratique de la
région centre asiatique avec
effectivement une régime parlementaire
depuis a depuis 2010 c'est un pays qu'on
dit instable assez rapide assez
rapidement mais en réalité plutôt stable
danser dans ses fondements en tout cas
de sarah constitution le vrai problème
en tout cas qu'on voit émerger avec avec
ces événements c'est une corruption
assez endémique depuis finalement l'
indépendance de l'urss en 91 qui
ressurgit aujourd'hui mais aussi le fait
que c'est une population qui a beaucoup
souffert de la crise de ducobu alors la
commission électorale qui annule les
résultats des législatives comment vous
appréciez cette annonce ben c'est tout à
fait surprenant d'avoir d'avoir
effectivement cette commission qui a
soutenu le processus électoral malgré
donc la crise de covin parce qu'il faut
savoir qu'effectivement il y avait de
grosses incertitudes serait tenue de
cette élection
donc à moi finalement il ya deux mois on
aura dit ok c'est bon on est parti
malgré ça elle annule dès le
surlendemain de
de l'élection c'est effectivement une
grosse surprise et c'est ce qui nous
amène à dire en tout cas dans un pays
qu'on a publié aujourd'hui qu'on est
potentiellement à l'aube d'une troisième
révolution pour aussi d'autres facteurs
qui font qu'aujourd'hui le le il ya
beaucoup beaucoup d'incertitudes et la
majorité de ce qu'on peut voir et
entendre est très très peu clair tant
pis justement quelles sont ces autres
facteurs dont vous me parlez
alors on a par exemple la des gisements
d'or qui ont été occupés par des
manifestants un peu partout dans le pays
l'union bancaire national à retirer tout
l'argent liquide des distributeurs de
billets des différentes banques du pays
notamment à bichkek la capitale
on a aussi donc le maire de bichkek la
capitale le maire josh est la seconde
ville de pays qui ont été démis de leurs
fonctions par des manifestants dont qui
ont été remplacés par des personnes qui
faisaient partie des manifestants
on a aussi des directeurs des dirigeants
de province deux régions qui ont été
remplacés de la même façon donc tout va
très vite
des chaînes de télé notamment à l'atome
24 une chaîne de télé nationale qui ont
été prises par les manifestants qui a
été ces cas dont les journalistes ont
été remerciés on a finalement beaucoup
d'incertitudes et et on a un vrai savoir
ce qui va ce qui va se passer ce qui est
intéressant en tout cas nous a observé
ses devoirs il ya un prêt une vraie
animation delà de la société contre donc
cette corruption endémique dont je vous
parlais à savoir notamment que les deux
parties qui ont été officiellement
reconnu vainqueur avant l'annulation des
résultats étaient
a priori déjà favori auparavant du fait
de leur pouvoir d'achat de votes
notamment leur puissance pour acheter
des votes et pour utiliser ce qu'on
appelle les ressources administratives
c'est à dire convaincre les
administrations publiques de dons par
les employés des administrations
publiques de voter pour eux s'ils ne le
font pas il pourrait elle pourrait donc
perdre leur poste m'ont finalement c'est
c'est un peu tout ça qu'on voit
aujourd'hui un autre facteur sait aussi
que la maison blanche donc dont vous
parlez dans votre sujet donc qui
regroupe le palais présidentiel et le
parlement a finalement n'a finalement
pas été défendu ou très peu par les
forces de l'ordre avance on avance on
son occupation par les manifestants ce
qui est effectivement pose question
parce que c'est quand même le grand
symbole politique kirghize de plus qui
regroupe donc et le bureau du président
et le parlement
alors est ce qu'il ya un pays dans la
région qui pourraient avoir un rôle de
médiateur dans cette crise qui
manifestement se dessine alors assez
naturellement du fait de leur lien la
russie effectivement peut se proposer
comme médiateur ils ont déjà donc la
russie a d'ailleurs réagi
là cet après midi à eau aux événements
actuels au kirghizstan après je suis pas
sûr exactement qu'on puisse faire appel
à un pays directement on a ville là tout
va se mettre en place au niveau 1 au
niveau local et interne a déjà un
conseil de coordination qui a été lancé
par les sept partis d'opposition qui ont
été d'ailleurs à l'origine de la
manifestation d'hier qui a dégénéré et
donc qui a abouti à la prise de la
maison blanche donc à mon avis on n'est
pas forcément la russie pour être là
mais c'est pas forcément le premier
acteur auquel on pense à mon avis ce
sera surtout les kirghizes eux-mêmes et
les partis politiques locaux qui vont
qu'ils vont essayer d'éclaircir la
situation
en sachant que déjà aujourd'hui j'ai pu
voir il ya pas là on n'y a pas si
longtemps une une photo et un témoignage
d'une personne sur place qui montrent en
fait que la situation reste
cannes en tout cas aux abords de la
maison blanche et qu'on est moins d'une
d'une situation de violence pure et dure
là l'heure actuelle merci d'avoir été en
direct avec nous monsieur combier je
rappelle que vous êtes le rédacteur en
chef de novastar médias traitant de
l'actualité sur l'asie centrale merci